the spread of this information and fake
news is a direct threat to our societies
it undermines our democracies it harms
our values and it
affects our interests but during a
pandemic
as the minister said this information
puts lives at risk
but not even deadly consequences have
stopped foreign actors from spreading
fake news
the amount of influence operations and
misleading campaigns
mainly from china and russia has been
massive
interference and hybrid warfare should
never be a strategy
but especially not during a global
health crisis
the commission's communication is
another important step towards a solid
comprehensive and effective strategy
against foreign interference
we need tougher regulations the eu has
been targeted with unprecedented actions
they require a firm and unprecedented
response
the smd group is at the forefront of
this fight
at our initiative today we will vote on
the establishment of a special committee
against foreign interference and
disinformation and urgent action is the
only way
to protect our democracies and the
european parliament
is ready to play that role thank you
very much